Instructor: One of
the reasons people haven't
picked ES6 just yet is they say, "
Well, it doesn't work in all the
browsers." That is not true for
the latest browsers, but it is
true if you have to support a
browser that is older than, I
don't know, a year or two old,
where they just don't know about
this ES6 things. However,
that should not stop you from
using ES6 today because it is
possible with Babel and
polyfilling to get probably
about 99 percent of all ES6
working across all the browsers
that you need to support.
What does that mean? I'm going
to explain to you what Babel is,
how we can set it up, and in the
next video I'm going to talk all
about using polyfills to
polyfill the new methods that we
haven't used. Babel, what is
it? I've been talking about it a
couple of videos and I've
referenced it, but I haven't
actually gone through it ahead
and say what it is. Essentially
it is a JavaScript compiler, and
what that means is you put
JavaScript in and you get ES5 or
a browser-compliant ES5 out.
It initially started with just
ES6 stuff, however it's really
expanded to future JavaScript
stuff, experimental JavaScript
stuff, a lot of React stuff is
also in it. Let's take a quick
look at how it works, and then
we'll step back. I'm just going
to go to babeljs.io and I'm
going to go to Try It Out.
This is really nice, because if
you're ever trying to understand
how something works you can just
go to the babeljs REPL right
here and try it out. Right
here, I've got this function
called log pet. It takes in a
pet name and it takes in a pet
type. However, we've got a
couple of ES6 things going on
here. I've got this petType =
dog, where I've set that as a
default, then I'm also using
template strings here. Now,
that works great, but what if
everyone is using the latest
Chrome? What Babel will do is
compile it down to what the
ES5 equivalent is, and it does a
fantastic job at doing that.
Never mind what this code
actually looks like, because
you're just concerned with how
this code looks like. Let's
take a look. Right here, petType =
dog, here it does a quick check
if someone has passed a second
argument, and if not, they set
petType to be = dog. Same thing
goes for when I am doing
concatenation here. This is
template strings, but this kicks
out actual annoying
concatenation. That's Babel
and we use it pretty much in
every single project that you
need ES6 to work with. It sort
of goes hand and hand with a
Webpack or a system JS. I've
already shown you how to use
Babel with Webpack. You only
need Webpack or system or a
Browserify if you are using
modules. If you're using
absolutely everything else,
there's no need for a Webpack or
a Browserify or anything like
that. If you just want to
write ES6 code and get it to
compile down without having to
use modules, then you don't need
a Webpack or anything like that.
You can have a much simpler
setup. I'm going to show you
how to do that now. Let's take a
look. Here we are in our ES6
tooling. Let's make a directory
called Babel and let's move into
Babel. Now, I need to set up
an npm package, we're going to
set npm in it, and now we have a
package.json file. Now we need
to install just two things
actually. We need to npm install
babel.cli. What that will do is
it allow us to run Babel via the
command line, or we're actually
going to do an npm script.
Then we also need what's called
a preset because Babel has these
plugins, if we go to plugins
here, and every single possible
feature that JavaScript has, has
a plugin. They sort of chunk
it out into different plugins,
so arrow functions, and block
scoping, and classes, and for...
of, and destructuring, and
spread, and every single
possible feature of ES6 is
available right here. But
then it also supports modules.
It also supports some
experimental like stuff that
might be added to the language
but we aren't quite sure just
yet. It supports some
minification stuff. It supports
a whole bunch of React stuff.
There's all kinds of stuff, and
probably you don't need all of
these. You just need all of the
ES6 stuff, so rather than you
having to download every single
plugin that you need here, they
also have this thing called
presets. A preset is simple,
just a collection of plugins, so
we don't need to install every
single ES6 plugin, we just need
to install one ES2015 preset, so
that's what we'll do. We'll
say babel-preset-ES2015, and
then we're going to save of
those to our packge.json.
Once it's installed you can
actually check your package.json
and you should see that we have
babel-cli and babel-preset
installed. Now that we have
that, we have this command
called Babel. You won't be able
to run it via the command line
unless you have installed that
globally, but we can run it via
an npm script. That's
actually what we're going to go
ahead and do, is we cab go into
our scripts here, we can delete
the test one, and we'll just
call that script called Babel.
The actual command that we run
is called babelapp.js, so we're
going to run the Babel command
against app.js, and we are going
to watch for changes, and we are
going to save the output out-
file to a file called app-
compiled.js. Now, a couple of
things we need here. First of
all, we need an app.js, so let's
go into our Babel and create a
file called app.js, and let's
just say const age = 100, const
people = Wes and Kate, and then
let's just say const full names =
people.map-name, we'll do an
arrow function, and then we'll
return the actual name
plus Bos on the end. What
did we use? We used const, we
used arrow function here, we
used implicit return, we used a
whole bunch of different ES6
features here, and ideally what
should happen if we take that
and try it out in the Babel
editor, it should compile that
down to using var. It should
properly scope the vars if I'm
inside of any blocks, and it
should make it a proper function
and use concatenation. How
can we do that here? Let's go
over to our package.json. Now we
have the script here. If we were
to run it, it wouldn't work just
yet, and I'll show you why...npm
run Babel. If we up our actual
app-compiled right here, it
kicks out or JavaScript file,
but none of it has changed at
all because Babel by default
just is a file mover. It
doesn't actually do anything
because we haven't told at which
plugins or which collections of
plugins, which is a preset, to
use. To tell it, we could have
done it on the command line here,
or better is to have what's
called a .babelrc file. A
babelrc file is very similar to
an ESLint file, where it will
check .file for your specific
settings. I actually don't
like to use a .babelrc file in
some of my tutorials because
it's a .file and it always gets
lost. People that have hidden
files don't copy it over, so one
little thing you can do is you
can actually put your babelrc
file inside of package.json,
which is really cool. We can
just go into our package.json,
go to the bottom here and add a
Babel. Now we are writing json
here. Make sure you use double
quotes. Our Babel file is
going to be a couple of things.
Which preset are we using? We'll
we are using ES2015, and that's
it. If you had multiple presets,
like you might also be doing
React, then you do React, like
that. However, we just have one.
That is our entire Babel config.
There's a whole bunch of other
stuff that you could possibly
put in there, and to find out
more about that you go to usage
cli, or go to usage babelrc, and
it's going to tell you
information that can possibly go
into it and you can check it all
out via the options on here.
File name, presets. See, that's
the one we're using. Plugins, if
you want to add an additional
plugin there. Highlight code,
ignore, etc., etc. All kinds of
fun stuff that goes in there,
but we really just need the
presets here. I think we
should be able to now run. Quit
it and then npm run Babel, and
it should kick out an app-
compiled. I open up my compiled
in new tab here...There we go,
look. It's telling me that we
use var here, we have full names,
it's using a proper function,
it's using concatenation. Now
any time that I write any sort
of ES6 in here, for person of
people, const, console.log,
person, give that a save, it
will rerun here, and look at
this. It does all kinds of crazy
stuff. It uses R4, it uses
the symbol iterator, it does all
of the hard work behind the
scenes to get this to actually
work, where we just have to
write the nice, clean ES6 and it
works extremely well.
Companies like Facebook are
using this to compile their
entire code base, so if it's
good enough for them it's
probably also good enough for
you. One other thing is if
you would like to add additional
plugins -- because our package.
json Babel preset is only ES2015,
but let's say you were
interested in trying some of the
other plugins out. One that I am
a big fan of under experimental
is this object rest spread.
Remember you learned about rest
and spread... and I said this
only works for arrays. It can
also work for objects, but it's
not in the language yet. It
hasn't totally done. What we
need to do is install this right
here, npm solve Babel plugin
transform object rest spread.
We take that to our command line.
Make sure that you save that
dependency, and now that we've
installed this right here we can
go to our package.json, and
instead of also using presets we
can use plugins, which is going
to be an array in itself.
The plugin that we are using is
the transform object spread, so
I should be able to now go into
my app.js and use some of their
rest properties or their spreads
properties, paste it in here.
Let me paste that at the top so
we can see it. Give it a
save, now I need to rerun it,
npm run Babel, and here we go,
you see that. They put in some
helper functions often object
without properties, and this is
our actual...It looks a little
bit funky sometimes, but they
know what they're doing and the
code actually turns out working
really nicely.